Welcome back everyone
Marvel's been teasing the Thunderbolts movie
They just announced that they're
introducing the sentry
during that. We think we know who that's
actually going to be, so we'll explain
how that's all tied together with what
Thunderbolt Ross and Val are doing.
It spills out of secret invasion
a lot of it's tied to what he was doing
with the Super Soldier program
because there are so many super soldiers
on the Thunderbolts as they announce them.
we also have a clip of the director
talking about what
the movie is actually going to be about,
like why they're bringing
all these characters together.
So of course, we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos, all do
more videos for the movie for the century
as we start to get more footage.
but it's basically like the MCU
introducing its version of Homelander.
someone who's totally crazy in nine
Invulnerable with crazy levels of power.
This is the clip of the director
talking about what
the movie is actually about characters.
And is there something specific
to those characters
that bring them together and something
that they're going through that is,
you know, the most
traditional superhero story
to be told? And
I think that's sort of similar to the way
that we're looking at thunderbolts.
But there is a real clear
take and perspective on these characters,
and there's a specificity to it
And then also, you know, John Waters,
my roommate from college,
and we're good friends.
And so knowing this, what a great
experience he had making those films.
and I even did unit on like the L.A.
portion of one of the Spider-Man movies.
So like having a little bit more kind
of connection or insight into that world.
But beyond that, it was just like
a really different approach
and a new kind of story to tell.
And there were so many things,
but it is, you know, it's not a sequel
and it's not, you know, yes,
these characters have appeared before,
but it is a new story
being told and a story,
I think, with a very different perspective
than maybe people are expecting.
And I think that that felt exciting
and felt like a real challenge worth
taking on.
when he talks about Bucky being the team
leader, bring everyone together
and they're dealing with something
together, it's
sort of like the sheer trauma,
like everybody has issues
that they've been dealing with
in all the previous movies.
They just spill over into this
and the sentry character because he is
one of the most messed up
characters in the MCU.
the reason why we're talking about
the century
is because you price on your feeds.
This week that Marvel revealed
they're casting an evil Superman character
from the comics to be one of the villains
of the Thunderbolts movie,
if not the main villain.
They're kind of doing that thing
where they say that
somebody is the main villain, but secretly
somebody else is actually the villain.
Like Thunderbolt
Ross Val is another good example,
kind of an anti-hero,
but also kind of one of the big
antagonists, a marvel Phase five.
we got a couple of teasers for what's
going on with that during Black Panther,
Wakanda forever with The Vow,
The Thunderbolt Ross Vibranium plot,
we also learned that they just recast
Harrison Ford in the MCU as Thunderbolt
Ross and will turn him into Red Hulk
during Captain America four,
which comes out
right before the Thunderbolts movie.
so all this stuff for the Thunderbolts,
the sentry is meant to be connected.
when you hear evil Superman in the MCU,
there are a couple of main characters
that come to mind,
mostly Sentry in Hyperion,
two completely different characters,
completely different backstories.
Hyperion isn't an eternal
like the ones we just saw in
the Eternals movie with the same backstory
as Superman from DC, like he was fired
from his dying planet to planet Earth.
and uses crazy Eternals powers
to become a more hardcore anti Superman
kind of character
within the ranks of Marvel's
heroes and villains in Squadron Supreme.
That's his big team.
His version of an Anti Justice League.
kind of like Marvel's version of the Boys
seven team Sentry is also like Marvel's
version of Superman with the twist
that he's totally schizophrenic.
He's a schizo type
of personality disorder.
Not the same thing that Moon Knight
suffered from, but similar.
Both of them have alternate personalities
like Moon Knight has Marc Spector.
Steven Grant
We just meet Jake Lockley
at the end of that series,
but he has something called
dissociative identity disorder,
century's real name is Robert Reynolds.
He started out as a drug addict
who was just down on his luck
and broke into a lab
where he thought he could find a score.
He took what he thought
was going to be drugs
that were going to get him high,
but it wound up giving him powers.
It wound up being the golden sentry serum,
which was a derivative
of the super soldier
serum, part of the weapons Plus program.
it gave him the power of a million.
Exploding suns like that
version of the super soldier
serum was way more potent than the version
that the other super soldiers
on the Thunderbolts
team got, or even Captain America got.
but the process of getting all that power
when he was already kind of broken
mentally caused him to develop
an alternate personality called the Void,
who's a totally evil version of himself
with an equal level of power,
but different types of powers
so a lot of his backstory
is similar to the backstory for Homelander
and the other boys superhero characters
getting their powers from Compound V
but the whole picture is
is he's mentally very broken
character he's not mentally stable.
So the whole idea is what if Superman
but he's totally crazy,
which is where you get to the century
in the MCU.
The reason why
I say the mystery evil Superman
that Marvel is introducing is century
and not Hyperion is because
of what Kevin Feige said at D23,
that Thunderbolts presentation
they revealed what's going on with Val
Thunderbolt Ross and their whole plot
to recreate super soldiers in the Weapons
Plus program.
This pays off a long running Easter egg
that I'll explain in the second
from the first Incredible Hulk movie.
in it, D23.
Kevin Feige very specifically remarked
that Winter Soldier was going
to be the most mentally stable person
on the Thunderbolts.
David Harbor, who plays Red Guardian.
So said, it's all about this group
of fundamentally broken people.
Mentally broken, that is.
Who have crazy levels of powers.
Who find a way to work together and help
heal each other slowly,
like, help each other
actually accomplish their mission, but
also fix a lot of their mental problems.
They've been suffering from in a lot of
them just happen to be super soldiers.
Kind of like Sentry is.
Technically, he's a super soldier,
even though it's a slightly
different version of the formula.
through Captain America
four In the Thunderbolts movie,
they're paying off this long
running Easter Egg from the Incredible
Hulk movie with the Weapons Plus program,
which is meant to be Thunderbolt,
Ross's renamed version
of the Super Soldier program.
So, for example,
Wolverine comes from the Weapon X program,
but X is a Roman numeral
that stands for ten.
He's the 10th version of the weapons
plus program of them
trying to recreate a super soldier
using different means.
all the members of the team here
come from some iteration of the weapons
plus program or some offshoot
in the case of the Winter Soldier
with Hydra's Winter Soldier program.
thunderbolt.
Ross's whole thing
with continuing the weapons plus program
during the Incredible Hulk movie
and then in the present day,
they don't use to create more
super soldiers, better weapons
that he wants to use
to defend the United States
from other future Threats like that
shows the program that Bruce Banner
was working on when he had his gamma
accident, giving him his whole powers
was secretly part of the weapons
plus program Thunderbolt
Ross just tricked him into working on it,
thinking that the program
was meant for something else.
And because he got his powers in the U.S.
military's lab,
like all the equipment that he was using
when he became the Hulk, belong
to the U.S. military thunderbolt.
Ross thinks of the Hulk
as the property of the U.S.
government and intends on taking that
power for himself to become Red Hulk.
I've already done a much larger red
Hulk video explaining the actual process
of how he became Red Hawk in the comics
and how they're changing that
for the movie.
So we'll link that at the end of this
and down in the description below
the reason why this is connected
to the origin of the century in the MCU
is because Sentry also got his powers
from a derivative of the super soldier
Serum Weapons Plus program in the comics
century came from the same place
Deadpool came from called Department
K, which was an offshoot of the Weapon
X program, the Wolverine program,
which itself was a further version
of the Weapons Plus program.
so the century's origin is meant
to be very similar to Homelander's origin.
A lot of the other boys characters, like
Soldier Boy, started out as a dirt bag
or were broken people mentally
and just got God tier powers.
He's meant to be
one of the most powerful characters
in the Marvel Universe
during World War Hulk, for example,
there's a bit of a World War
hold plot that they're using
for Captain America
four In the Thunderbolts movie,
it seems like he was able to fight
world breaker hold to a standstill
with the fight
just going on
until they eventually wore each other out
because neither one could kill each
other. But.
Even though they say
he has the power of a million
exploding suns, his actual powers
go way beyond Superman types of powers.
He has molecule manipulation
and superspeed flight immortality.
He can heal people
extreme regeneration faster than Deadpool
and Wolverine's regeneration Night.
Invulnerability, telepathy.
He can create forcefield
shapeshifting energy manipulation,
whether manipulation In the comics,
the way that introduces
character is in a Rashomon
kind of story where he just wakes up
confused in present day,
this kind of overweight, middle aged man
not really understanding what's going on,
but slowly remembering who he is.
He's sentry.
He has all these got to your powers
Eventually he learns that in order
to protect the world
from his evil persona, the void
he caused the entire world to forget
about the century, including himself.
it was a way for Marvel to explain
how he was created back
during the 1950s, 1960s,
and he'd been alive this entire time.
While you're having all these adventures
with The Avengers,
all these big crossovers,
but you're only learning
about the century.
In the early 2000s,
when they first introduced the character,
nobody knew about him
because they pulled a Spider-Man.
No way home. It was just like the movie.
Just cause everybody on the planet
to forget about the century.
at least until he remembered everything
which caused the evil persona
within his mind to resurface the void,
bringing that threat back as well.
so the whole idea is he's
so unpredictable, so crazy
that it's even harder
to deal with him as a character
and get him to do what you want than it is
to deal with a version of the full Hulk,
like the mindless Hulk.
so the idea during the Thunderbolts movie
is that you have this mentally unstable
team of anti-heroes trying to take down
or talk down the sentry
in insurmountable nine invulnerable
and totally crazy force.
so part of the whole joke
here, part of the pitch
is that they have zero chance against him.
Like there's no way
that they be able to stop him.
He's that powerful in faced with that,
how do they wind up taking him down
or talking him down, talking him
back to his senses And a lot of
this is about getting over past trauma
and dealing with your mental problems.
They kind of address that during Falcon
in Winter Soldier with Winter Soldier's
character being in therapy and slowly
working through his problems
So right now my early theory is, is
they have to face the sentry.
There's no way they can beat him
and they won't beat him.
They'll find a way to talk him back
to his senses The big surprise, though,
the actor they're supposedly
casting as sentry is Steven Yeun
because Jake Schreier, the director,
also did be the Steven Yeun series.
there's also why I've been using
all the invincible means during this video
just ironic that it winds up being.
Steven Yeun In the MCU.
Let me know in the comments where you want
Sentry to show up after this movie too,
because it sounds like he's
going to be a pretty big character.
There's a whole bunch of stuff coming up
to make sure to enable alerts for my.
Chelsea Don't miss anything.
Asoka Episodes start next week.
Click here for that big Marvel Doctor
Strange three announcement and click here
for all my Deadpool 3 videos.
Thank you so much for watching
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!